foreign
T is going to start us off this hour Hi
Brent welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it and Merry Christmas to you
Merry Christmas how can we help
well uh my wife and I just kind of have
a kind of a quick question here
hopefully but I'll give you some numbers
um we're 32
and we're kind of on baby steps six-ish
we live in two places because we work in
two different places
um one of our homes in in our
dates is paid off and it's worth about
380k and then the other house that we
have is worth about 950
000 and we owe about 540 on it
um and then we also own a commercial
building that my business operates out
of it's worth about 300 000 and we owe
170 000 on that
um our retirement account is at 260 000.
so the kicker here is that we have a
two-year-old and a four month old
and my wife makes about 220k a year and
she'd like to become a stay-at-home mom
and I don't know about 18 months or so
but so when she leaves her job uh we'll
probably sell one of our homes in one of
those places we haven't decided where
yet
um and then we'll probably go down to an
income of about 40
000 maybe 45 000 a year
um what
do you make now
yeah for like forty five thousand
and a three hundred thousand dollar
commercial building
Yeah so basically I bootstrapped a
business from like the ground up and so
uh because I'm essentially not there
half of the year uh it's a it's that um
I don't pay myself a whole bunch of
money because I'm not there just to make
sure that I can keep employees kind of
operating while I'm away
so what are you doing when you're away
taking care of my kids so you're staying
at home half the year
yeah
she's in a different city
yeah so so we live together every time
in each different city so when she's
working here in Austin I'm here in
Austin but I'm taking care of the kids
when we go to Minnesota that's when I
work but then she stays at home and
takes care of the kids
what does she do
she's in Academia she's a professor
okay
so that that's kind of you so you know
kind of what those income levels look
like okay so we're going to combine
households and land in one place which
place are we going to land Austin or
Minnesota
we don't know that yet
yeah well um I mean I like your value
system and where you're headed because
the way you're living life now is kind
of cray-cray
um and uh so I I like you know the
direction you're moving with this but
um but I think your destination needs
some refinement
um meaning I don't know why she has to
go from 225 to 0.
there's a lot of options in Academia
that uh she could make eat you know work
uh just a few hours a week and make 50
to 100K if we line this up properly and
um and you know we're not going to
accept your business which absolutely
sucks as our final destination
okay you two are you two are high
capacity people you should your goal
should not be we're gonna live on forty
five thousand dollars
okay I think you can land better than
that I still get the quality of life all
in one city and her being at home
largely with the kids if not completely
with the kids
um and and that's a good baby step in
between these two but just to suddenly
take a machete to this thing you've
built is not a good plan
okay so I think you need a better plan
on where you're going to land and she
needs an adjusted plan on where she's
going to land and that's going to put
you guys well up over a hundred and
you've got a sustainable situation then
that's not as bizarre as you originally
outlined when you came on because dude I
mean you have to admit what you're
outlining is pretty bizarre
oh yeah it's wild yeah that's why we
called yeah what kind of business are
you running
so it's it's like a retail it's um it's
a retail business it does like we do
some
um
uh like training we do some like like
physical fitness training things like
that and then we have some products and
random things like that and I don't we I
don't foresee that being our full-time
business uh you know it's just like
right now if we had a fallback and
because her family is there and that's
where our families are up in Minnesota
we could operate yeah it's like we could
operate there for as long as we wanted
um I wouldn't land there out of
convenience what I want you to do is
have some intentionality about both of
your careers and your location
and go okay then that will tell you how
you can back into this and say over the
next 18 24 months whatever we can make
these six moves uh two of them on her
career two of them on your career two of
them on the real estate decisions and
then that will put us in this this other
position that is a sustainable life then
with a standard Rhythm to it
but um I mean I I don't blame you for
wanting to change the way that you guys
are living now it's kind of wild and
um it's been you know it's obviously run
its course it's time it's time for you
to do something different so
um but
but I think the uh the fact that this
season is over has led you all to just
this extreme thing of nothing
we're going from uh 100 miles an hour to
full stop and I I think you can go from
100 miles an hour down to 50 miles an
hour between the two of you I income
wise and by the time you're located and
get the efficiency of being in one
location sell off a piece of real estate
open a business don't open a business
expand the one you've got take a
different career field I don't care
and part of this is getting rid of some
of this debt and so the commercial debt
the personal debt of the mortgage the
sooner you guys are completely debt free
and your personal life and your
professional life the easier it's going
to be to make these kinds of financial
decisions yeah yeah that's going to put
you in the right direction
but the the beautiful part about both of
your
skill sets is they can be scaled up or
down they don't have to go zero or not
or 100 miles an hour
you don't have to be all or nothing and
so
um
higher ed is
like a lot of things is being impacted
by the digital world and is morphing and
so she's just got other choices
um that she can look at Now teach a few
classes online doesn't have to be zero
scale it down yeah the amount of
mentoring and uh
tutoring all kinds of different things I
don't know exactly what she's doing in
Academia but um there's a lot of
there's a lot of options in that world
right now because they don't have a lot
of choices they're going to have to
provide options